now speaking about the last and final
message upon Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him who had mentioned
in a authentic tradition can you comment
on this because it goes with what we're
talking about the heart he said there's
a more so in the body that if it's sound
the whole body will be sound of his
corrupt the whole body will be corrupt
can you comment on this and then he said
that that morsel is the heart heart to
heart now there's I just wanted to the
item on the heart speaking of the heart
and having a sound heart the prophets
awesome mentioned a narration in which
he mentions there's a man who lost his
child a young child an infant and Allah
he actually describes the conversation
that takes place between Allah and the
angels and a las pathol obviously knows
exactly what happened but this
conversation is described by the proper
system so that we can learn something
from it and take away a very important
lesson he describes that this Allah
Allah spotless as to the Angels that you
took the soul of the infant of my slave
the Angels say yes we did that was what
was commanded to us he asks did you take
away the apple of his eye the bottom
samurott avoir de he the fruit of his
heart is literal translation the better
transition will be the apple of his eye
the joy of his life and they say the
angels say yes hamada caller Abdi what
did my slaves say when this tragedy
happened the angel said Hamid acha was
star John he praised you and he said in
a lillahi what in ilayaraja rune be to
Allah we are we belong to Allah and we
will return to Allah and then a lot
father said build a house in Jenna for
this slave and call it the house of
praise the point is that this man
anonymous not named in this narration
this could be any
this could be anybody in the crowd
anybody who's this thing anybody who
suffered this incredible loss this could
be any of those people this is a person
who is demonstrating what it means to
have a sound heart that they have this
connection with a loss pathol even in
the most difficult time in their life
when they've just lost their child
they're still able to remember allah and
not just remember allah thank Allah and
remind themselves that we are in fact we
belong to Allah and we will eventually
return to him those DD those actions at
the strike of the most difficult
calamity that shows the true soundness
of the heart we're talking about having
us out the sound heart at the sound
heart convention in toronto canada we'll
be right back this is the
this is the thing you know this is the
danger this is the things you and we're
talking about the heart I mean right now
we live in a generation whereas I this I
that iphone imac all of these eyes and
we're charging these things so how can
someone charged the heart of you now
like they know okay I can plug this in
and my iphone get charged but how do you
charge the heart I think one of the most
significant aspects of connecting one's
heart to Allah is through the ritual
aspects that are requested of us and you
know God asks us really simple things
you know God has a right upon us he's
the one who has given us everything that
we have and he asked for us you know to
pray five times a day and those prayers
though cyclical consistent every day of
every week of every month till death
surprises us is a constant connection
the word for prayer is called Salah
which means Silla it's a connection to
God and and and that's a you know it's a
profound statement that we connect
ourselves to him constantly in prayer I
will pray or it's not just simply saying
I need this and I want you to protect me
from that but it's more about praise you
know you began by saying Allahu Akbar
everyone said Allahu Akbar everything
that is done well and significantly
deserves an ovation you know if a
concert or a pianist does something
great people listen to it they were
enthralled at the end of it they all
stand up and they you know that it's
like wow when they applauded and it was
in appreciation and for us that standing
before God and the Declaration of Allah
who o'clock nothing is greater for me
than God nothing is of more benefit to
me than God no one can help me more than
God no problem is too great than a
all of that solidifies the heart like it
makes your heart firm and it gives you a
surety and resilience in the tempest of
the world and the difficulties that we
experience so I think that's the
beginning point where we seek to reclaim
our heart that we lay it bare to the one
who sees in it Subhan Allah tada how
what kind of advice would you give for
someone you just mentioned to reclaim
your heart so someone has given their
heart to materialism they just want the
latest car and they feel that's going to
make them happy you know stick in and
just wait for the next fashion design to
come out and they're just engrossed
intoxicated with all of the things that
are out there of entertainment and now
the heart is connected to all of these
celebrities and all of the other wild
stuff that's out there and now you just
mentioned reclaim you need to reclaim
your heart what advice would you give to
someone who tuned in right now and
they're like you know what I want to
reclaim my heart I think there's there's
a number of ways but one thing that I
usually suggest and recommend people to
do if you really want to soften your
heart and reclaim it look at people to
have less than you you know today like
you mentioned we live in a day and age
where we've got iphones and ipads and
you know gadgets and tablets and
technology and it's everywhere like even
my watch beeps and vibrates when it's
time for me to you know wake up in the
morning the alarm and it's just crazy i
get my messages you make phone calls
like our life is just revolved around
the world and not everyone has that and
you know an example that I like to use
in terms of you know just to make people
understand what I'm trying to say is
remember those who have less than you i
remember when i went to the Philippines
at one point in time and i asked the
brothers and the sisters you know what i
said during my trip i really want to go
to the slums and they're like the slum
like it's dangerous why would you want
to go there so they took me to the slums
and while i was there you know i saw
children
who for us like today we see children
playing with iPads and the parents don't
even know how to use it these children
would go down to the stream where the
sewage water would flow into and they
would get little pieces of like wood or
straw or some piece of cardboard from
like someone's juice box and they'd rip
it rip it off and go back up to the
stream of sewage water flowing down the
hill and they would race it and see
who's piece of garbage reached the
garbage at the bottom before the other
kids and so that was their joy that was
their passion that's that's what they
you know felt happy with and to eat they
would go to the garbage cans the
dumpsters and take out the bones from
the fast food chicken that we finished
eating they would take it out bring it
home chop it up again re spice it fry it
and then add water to boil it into a
soup and that was their food our
leftovers that they took out of a
garbage from a fast food restaurant so
there's people that don't have what we
have and to I think sometimes we just
need to literally go down to the slums
of whatever city we're living in or go
to the you know whatever area has poor
people usually a downtown or central you
know area of the city where there's
homeless people living and give them
from the best of what we have so go to
your closet take out your Armani suit
your you know Giorgio Armani's and your
perfume bottles and you know four
sisters get out some of your jewelry or
whatever or something that's useful for
those people so socks and clothing and
nice you know down duvets and comforters
that we sleep with and go and give it to
them and feel what it feels like to give
someone else what you enjoy and see the
smile on their face your heart softens
immediately great advice how about for
the person now the brothers like I left
you know my my heart with that honey at
the club and she's like you know what
I'm just thinking about committing
suicide if I can't get this man and
she's living in fantasyland and you have
an opportunity now that they're
listening how can you get someone like
this from your experience to reclaim
their heart so
the what advice do you like to give ya
so somebody who's literally heartbroken
there's you can say to them look sad
than the world there's lots of people
there right this inefficiency for all of
us part of the analogy and the second
thing is that you remind ourselves that
Alice Wanda says in the Quran mind the
commune fat momma in the LA he buck that
whatever you have is going to end and
whatever Allah span Tala has is always
going to last it's always going to be
there so we aim for what a lost patla
has that's Jenna we aim to get there if
you want everlasting love we aim to get
to Jenna because that's where we'll get
that love if you want everlasting
pleasure we aim for that in Jenna and
then we will have it so just that
perspective that gets of course we all
want pleasure and enjoyment in this
dunya as well but the perspective has to
be there that whatever we have in this
dunya is going to end it's going to
wither away the shine will wear off but
whatever Allah sparkler has Anjana never
will it never build a shine wear off in
fact it will get even better and better
just as an example the people who go to
agenda the prophets awesome told us that
a man will leave his house in Jenna come
back home and he would say to his wife
you're more beautiful than my left shoe
that she was said no you're more
handsome when you left right so your
beauty increases day by day and your
love increases moment by moment agendas
panel how beautiful is that so we aim
for that and we keep then our minds for
we're almost out of time before we close
it up now for the not yet Muslims
because everyone has the potential to
submit to God alone to worship the
Creator not the creation and they're
tuning them we talk about God which I'm
at the heart and people are realizing
that okay you know what I can't get
happiness and all of these materials
superficial things but now they're like
okay i'll just go join this religion
that religion all these religions out
there how do i know what you guys are
talking about is the way of life that's
definitely
the crater with all these other
different religions claiming that
they're the way and the only way the
right way how can I differentiate which
one is truly the way from God ultimately
truth is always set apart from falsehood
and you know as a person who was born
into Islam I see you know I always ask
myself would I come to Islam would I've
walked over to Islam had I not known it
by the blessing of having been given it
from birth and you know some time allow
those who come into faith you know a lot
describes them in the Quran that Allah
open their chest to the truth and you
know the verses in the Quran which is
always the first step to faith for me I
always recommend to people to read the
Quran read it on your own don't don't
don't see higher interpretation just
read and I do recommend you know the
Oxford University Press edition dr.
Halim's translation of the Quran it's
very accessible to an English market to
an English reader it's very clear it's
very polished and there's no added
commentary there's no added values that
are added to it so just read what the
man interpreted God's word has been and
you know I I just want to share with you
like an experience of one of you know a
peep one of my friends from high school
and he was over over at my house when we
were young and you know I'd never you
know shared the four on with him we said
read this or you know nothing like that
and I walked out of the room came back
and he was crying and he was standing
near in my desk and he said I said
what's wrong with you I thought
something you know something happened I
go what's wrong with you and he goes you
know and he pointed to the Quran he just
tapped it like this he said this is the
truth and he goes I want to be a Muslim
I said aloha you know why he goes well
you know I always wanted to read it but
I felt like I didn't want to ask you so
when you went out I just turned it over
and I read the first sentence the first
sentence I read it's the truth so I said
well what's his sentence and I look in
it and it was from Surat Annisa
allah subhana allah says in a ladina
kaduna a moi lolita maluma enemy Haruna
feeble to knee him Nava those who
consume the wealth of the orphans
unjustly they are ingesting in
themselves Hellfire now what I didn't
know about my friend was that he was an
orphan child and he was from one foster
home to the next and he was put in
neglectful homes where the money that
the state the government paid towards
their fair to him was usurped by others
it was gone in the form of liquor and in
the form of other things and no one
cared for him and he as a young child
grew up seeing that those who were paid
to look after him failed him and the
first verse that he opened and looked at
in the Quran moved his heart that he
said this is the truth the one who did
this to me God is not unjust my life is
not something that was wasted the
tragedies I experienced there will be
recompensed and you know the brother now
alhamdulillah is in Toronto married with
four children you know Muslim mashallah
and you know that I say to you know I
were our brothers in humanity or sisters
in humanity read the Quran you have
nothing to lose begin from anywhere you
like if you're a Christian you want to
read about what we say about Jesus open
the 19th chapter read about Mary you
know the mother of Jesus read his story
his immaculate birth you know what we
believe if you want to know you know
what are the things that we value look
at look at how God describes you know
Heaven and Hell in the final chapters of
the Quran just read read read and that's
the first word of the Quran o'clock the
aim of it just read you have nothing to
lose give us some closing comments
suggestions on the heart or anything
else we in a tweet what you what you can
fin the tweet where we got two minutes
so we want to get both for you in so in
a tweet give them some advise some
encouragement take it away
you know what Eddie it's tough to do
these tweets you keep giving me tweet
give him the tree let him start with the
tweet i also had a dream i have a friend
from university it's gonna be a little
long to tweets ok who inspired me to
take a stab seriously i was just a
cultural muslim born in a Muslim family
he was a convert and I saw him and I was
so inspired by his practice practice of
Islam we used to put in during exam time
skip prayer right during the exam if the
horse allow came and went we would be
like whatever he said how could you do
that right he said I would start he
would leave an exam go outside and pray
and come back and then finishes exam so
panola and that just that action was so
moving that all of us were young and saw
him were inspired so I asked him how did
you convert to Islam he said I read
surah Yousuf the translation and I said
this has to be from God it can be from a
human being well should give me a
facebook to it post all right i'll give
you a tweet you know you need God and or
sorry you know you could recognize God
when you're flying at 36,000 feet
watching your favorite movie and
turbulence hits and you could feel your
heart in your throat that's where you
recognize the entire plane just start
yelling oh my god and that's where you
realize you need God so everyone needs
God and everyone recognizes that they
need God they just don't know it until
some sort of turbulence hits in their
life and that's that moment there are no
atheists in foxholes have you heard the
same hamdillah at the sound heart
conference with our beloved shake thank
you so much we started with peace we end
with peace and I'm like I'm what peace
be with you sit on Lake the line and for
the not yet Muslims tuning in when
you're seeking the truth and you want to
know the truth God Almighty Allah the
Creator will facilitate away and for
those who have accepted Islam we need to
make it a full time gig not a part-time
gig and then we will reap all the
benefits and have a sound heart so at
the end
of not only the day but life we can get
to Jenna and avoid the Hellfire tune in
every week to the D show subscribe if
you haven't already Facebook Twitter
Follow us keep up with us make dua for
us we'll see you next time peace be with
you tuck beard everybody thank you for
coming out and being with us make sure
also support the program tune in to the
Dean show calm through there you can
find our youtube channel will have this
show up soon inshallah for those that
don't catch us on the satellite TVs like
us on the facebook to twitter and share
our shows so more people can benefit and
you can get the reward inshallah thank
you very much so i'm making peace yeah
just yet
yeah just one
please subscribe to the DVR follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below please also help
support the V show by making a donation
in the link below